well we asked you to tell us about the
remarkable women here in our community
and you deliver yeah eight news now we
got about 100 submissions and narrowed
it down to four finalists and throughout
March we're going to introduce you to
the remarkable women of Southern Nevada
and this morning Kirsten Joyce profiles
a woman changing the lives of homeless
here in our area
I would love to not have a job I would
love if there was no homeless Meredith
Spriggs is a special lady with the Heart
of Gold overseeing seven different job
sites across the valley with her
non-profit carida I have much smarter
people than myself that work under me
and a great board that supports us she
doesn't take herself too seriously and
that's what makes her so approachable to
the many residents here at Hebron I
always get on a smile and uh through
that smile you know it's magnetic she's
got a lot to smile about now but that
wasn't the case in 2008 when Meredith
battled her own time with homelessness
in 2008 I had a master's degree and went
from working in a university to living
on the Streets of San Diego employer
took me to court and took away my
unemployment and so my wages were
garnished and it was the week that the
market crashed I got that decision so I
worked two part-time jobs and couldn't
afford to live indoors in San Diego
after nearly a year on the street she
got established and realized she could
impact change for others I don't look
like the typical homeless person that I
could share those stories and educate
the public fact versus fictions the
karida charity was born the slogan
humanizing homelessness I am not a
serious person but also that was my
commitment to my friends on the streets
that we would never be that sad homeless
charity in 2014 she moved to Las Vegas
brought the charity with her over the
years receiving major support and
funding I joke that we've gone from
being the stinky kid in the back of the
class to the pretty girl that gets
picked for all the dances so it's kind
of nice that we have this successful
program helping with job reintegration
housing and food for veterans here at
Hebron when the successes do come in
when we get somebody stably housed or we
get them a job after they've been trying
for years it's just amazing to see those
success stories and when they do come
through it's what keeps me going because
unfortunately there's a lot of really
bad days because she's still frustrated
with the system her long-term goal to
implement the program around the country
and train others how to do it we are
fixing homelessness and we've proven it
now with the data by restoring people
back into community that they've been
broken from and we're giving them things
to do people here very much have things
to do in the daytime even if they have
zero income and they are housed here and
they're supported we give them tasks
they come and they volunteer they are a
part of this community
Kirsten Joyce 8 News Now
other successes include securing a
Haynes sponsorship for new socks and
underwear for the homeless she also
established a partnership with life is
beautiful in fact 10 people's lives were
changed when they were hired to clean up
Fremont Street and Alleyways this past
year